joining us here now uh reached out to
him uh with the scheduled release the
monday night football booth
steve levy brian gracie and this man
whose work i uh
always enjoy uh tapping into when he
calls into this show
louis riddick how are you sir i'm doing
good rich how are you man i'm doing fine
we saw what's going on in your life tell
us about your new av equipment you're
all fired up
we saw that you know you can just tell
like i'm i get bored sometimes
yeah it's just it's this thing that just
the little things man and i think for
for me a nice big new tv
surround sound you know i hadn't
upgraded my tv
in my house in a while okay and i was
out at best buy the other day and i was
like that's it that's it
there's one i was like what's the
biggest you got i can fit in my living
room with the biggest you got
like we got this new 75-inch samsung 8k
blah blah blah i was like i need
somebody to come to my house and hook
this thing up
so they they just came and hooked it up
and man i'm like my boy
who's homeschooling right now uh for
this year
yes he's like dad we're watching seth
curry tonight on that right though i'm
we're all fired up here yes
yes indeed watching steph take his ten
dribbles breaking ankles and then
doing his mvp thing that'll be fun for
you and the fam great that's awesome
uh let's jump into some football here
before we get to the monday night
football schedule
what just your keen insights to front
office work and how things work
what do you think is going on with aaron
rodgers and the packers
louis yeah you know
i think yeah andrew brandt put it real
succinctly
i mean i'll kind of paraphrase what he
said but he said you know with uh
with a unique skill set like aaron has
and with all the
with the unique skill sets that all the
great players that we
that we watch no matter what sport comes
the leverage to ask for a different
treatment for special treatment
because now i think players are more
aware than ever rich i mean obviously i
mean you you talk to them all the time
on your show the great players of
you know of the modern era that they're
more aware now of the kind of power that
they wield the kind of influence that
they have over their respective
organizations and the leagues overall
that they participate in
and when you don't kind of respect
that awareness as a decision maker team
builder owner whatever it is and you
just think that it is
that it's like how it used to be like in
the late 80s early 90s and i say that
because
during my time in the nfl mid-90s it's
which is if you think it's like that
skill where players just kind of just
always automatically universally just
about team team team
all right that's fine i'm going to kind
of de-program myself i'm not going to
worry about me it's just about the team
and coaches can just shove that kind of
stuff down your throat over and over and
over again
and you'll constantly just accept what
they say if you think that that's the
way things still
are then you're you lack awareness and
you lack the ability to adapt to how
things are done now and i think green
bay because you know i heard i heard
somebody say this i believe
dan graziano said it on our network this
morning about the fact that brian
gutenkins has been with the packers
basically his entire
life in terms of his front office his
front office career starting off as a
college scout i believe he was the
college scouting director and i remember
you know when i was in the front office
that he was you know on the road for
them at that time
and he does things kind of the way
they've always been done up there in
green bay
that you know when um ron wolf was
running the show ted thompson was
running the show
and now he's running the show that
that's how they've always done it we
make the decisions
we do what's in the best interest of the
football team the players kind of follow
suit
and that's how they kind of expect it to
be and
i think there's been it seems to me like
there's been a huge miscalculation as to
how that was going to be received by a
guy like aaron rodgers who i think we
all know is
a pretty individual you know a pretty
strong individual who has his own
set of expectations and ways that he
that he views things
and if you're not willing to adapt to
that and you're just going to think well
he's just going to fall in line and
accept things
the way we do things like everyone else
has always done over the years then
i just think that that this shows a
stunning lack of awareness and you
better be willing to communicate with
guys like that and give them a heads up
and not not embarrass them so to speak
look
andy reed used to tell us this all the
time in philly um
about how much it is a communication and
relationship business that it's always
going to come down to that
and he used to kind of he used to
conduct himself that way
whenever there was a big transaction in
philly whether it was we were bringing
someone in that was
kind of a well-known high-profile player
or we were getting rid of a well-known
high-profile player
he didn't let the scouting department or
the head of personnel handle it
he handled it he was the one who wanted
to communicate because he said those
guys
had earned that level of respect to
where they could
they deserve to have an audience with
the head coach with the guy who was the
central figure of the organization
and so if you're going to move up into
the first round
and draft the quarterback and he's going
to find out about it
watching tv like the rest of the fans
are watching it
how do you think a guy like that's going
to react and if there's more stuff
behind the scenes that he's already been
picked off about
or rather that has rubbed in the wrong
way just from a personal one-on-one type
situation that's just gonna that's just
adding fuel to the fire and it just
seems like
that's what from from my intel gathering
that's what this comes down to that's
not a money issue it's not it's nothing
like that
it's truly a respect and communication
issue
and when you're a guy like aaron and you
see the kind of influence tom has in
tampa bay
the kind of things that russell was
saying out there in seattle
and you're seeing more and more guys
especially at the quarterback position
as you know
who know that certain the teams just
cannot
you're not going to be able to function
without me you're going to what it's in
your best interest to have me healthy
both mentally and physically and have me
engaged in every
facet of this organization if you really
want to get to where you want to get to
it's just weird to me that you wouldn't
have that kind of awareness and you
wouldn't
kind of give aaron that kind of respect
the last thing i'll say about
lesson i'll say about that is this yes
sir and i know i've been going on and on
here but
this is something that i feel really
strongly about please
after the super bowl when patrick was
running for his life in that game
against the bucks
yeah brett beach is a good friend of
mine the general manager of the chiefs
and when brett was this basically andy's
andy's helper in in
philadelphia before he ascended to the
career he has now
you know i used to talk to him about all
all facets of team building and just
player interaction and all that and when
i talked to him after the super bowl
i said so you're doing all right and he
said man
no matter what i have to do i got to
protect patrick
i've got to protect the quarterback
nothing else matters but making sure
that this guy understands
that i am going to protect him and make
sure that i
give him everything he needs so that
never happens again what happened in
that super bowl
because that's on me that that feels
personal to me i cannot let that happen
again
and see that right there like he knows
he knows it doesn't it it doesn't go any
further than that i mean
they can't get it where they want to get
to unless that guy is taken care of
and i just don't understand like with
aaron rodgers different scenario
different kind of situation
but you should you should just naturally
i believe
have that kind of that kind of
interaction and that kind of
relationship with someone who plays such
a pivotal role in your success or
failure
as a gm so and and what you just said
louis riddick
um you know i i kind of echoed um
or i i said the same thing uh last week
that i frequently have conversations
with my kids
um huh that's conversation is just a way
for me to put it
uh in this life my wife and i as well
like when
they do something and we react sternly
there's one way to put it um sometimes
i'll say well
what did you expect our reaction to be
based on that behavior
like that's the sort of way like so so
you saying hey you know how what do you
expect the guy's reaction to be when
he's sitting at home with a stiff drink
watching the draft and he sees jordan
love traded
for to go get so that's the question i
have for you is like
is this really all about not getting a
heads up i mean or is it on top of the
fact that corey linsley is now a charger
and things of that nature uh you know
so so so how is how is this if we are to
you know hear my colleague at nfl media
group and james jones or john [ __ ]
that this is fixable how how do we how
do we put this all together
like guttacoon says i'm really really
sorry like
how does this actually fix it what's up
i don't know
and you know what i think rich when it
when it becomes
something that's that transcends
business
and it just becomes personal like
there's probably people that you that
you know in life that no matter what
once they kind of like rub you the wrong
way
they may be able to quote unquote fix it
with you to the point where maybe you're
cordial with them and you know
you know you don't hold a whole lot of
uh you know real negative
animosity towards them to the degree
where you know it affects you
you know day to day but you're able to
you're able to tolerate them but it
doesn't mean you necessarily would want
to
engage in you know go golfing with them
or you'd want to go into a business
venture with them or
you would want to work with them and if
it's to that point we're there and i
mean i don't know i mean
he hasn't spoken about it you know he
hasn't made any public statement about
it
so i don't really know how fixable it is
until
he gives us more clarity on exactly
where he's at with it how personal it is
between him and brian goodigan
and if it is something that an apology a
real sincere apology a real real real
sincere apology
will make it so he goes hey you know
what yeah i'll come back because my boys
are there you give me the best chance to
win you are paying me a lot of money i
would like to finish my career
in one place until he says something
we're all just guessing
because for some people and look i'm i'm
i'll be the first person to raise my
hand i'm guilty of it too for sometimes
once it becomes personal and crosses a
certain point
i don't care what you say to me i'll be
cordial with you
but i wouldn't want to work with you i
wouldn't want to be around you anymore i
wouldn't want to deal with you in that
way and we don't know if it's reached
that point with him
so until he says so we're just going to
be kind of like uh
discussing it and guessing louis riddick
here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about the monday night
football schedule sir you and steve levy
and brian greasy in the booth
really enjoyed listening to you guys
watching you guys last year
much is being made for the first game
because you're going to be in vegas with
people and stuff that'll be great but
i mean like let's just say rogers does
somehow someway pull and emmett right
you got you got the packers first home
game on monday night football man
i mean that could be quite something i'm
wondering
what your thoughts on that and what else
leaps out on this schedule for monday
night football
yeah um there would be something i mean
[Applause]
obviously i think the world you know the
world would be
much happier the football world and
particularly much happier if he does
if he does show up obviously yes us we
want to see as many great players as we
possibly can i mean we
we all know the people who cover this
business that one great quarterbacks are
on the field
it's just better for us all i mean we
solved that way with the draft when
there's stuff that when the news is just
kind of
kind of centered around quarterback play
it's just better it just feels more
exciting and more electric and i think
that that'll be no different for us and
we'll all be watching that to see
you know just how this all gets resolved
i think the slate of games overall
which is just you know there's just so
many good divisional matchups
there's i think for me personally
obviously that first game of the year
is is always anything that involves the
raiders is very near and dear
to my heart i think going out there to
vegas having been there last year with
no one in there i mean absolutely nobody
and
it was just such a weird weird surreal
experience being out there with no one
there in this
great big beautiful stadium i think when
you juxtapose that with how it's gonna
potentially look this week
this year rather i mean i i couldn't be
more fired up for the opening game and
that's not just hyperbole i mean that's
that's for real obviously i think i
think it's week 13 december the 6th
the patriots go to buffalo oh yeah
that's
another one that i have circled because
i mean they got swept last year the
patriots did
um we saw them on monday night late in
the season
up in in foxborough when buffalo came in
there and basically just
punched them right in the mouth and
pushed them all over the places and they
took cam out of the game in the second
half and
let jared spit him finish the game and
i've never seen bill look so defeated in
my life
so that game going into buffalo buffalo
is the place i've been
so many times when i was a kid my
brother was playing for the bills i
remember going up there and
running out on the field and looking up
to cornelius bennett and bruce smith and
all those guys when i was a
teenager and a freshman in college i
mean that's those kind of those kind of
things are just
i mean there's so many different games
there's i probably could tell you a
story about every game
how it touches me personally you know
yeah you guys that's what's
that's what's weird about this for me
it's hard to believe that i'm still
doing this you are great at it louis so
you shouldn't say that another second
eagles cowboys is a great
matchup that's week three week four is
raiders chargers you want to talk about
a beautiful stadium that's so fast
stadium where the super bowl is going to
be
that's going to be great seeing justin
herbert on a national stage
then you've got later on you've got two
nfc west hilts and i think that's the
best division in football
rams are at 49ers you also have rams at
cardinals that's
after the patriots and bills before you
finish up with vikings bears
dolphin saints right in the middle of
the big finale browns and steelers then
you got that double dip
on the final uh weekend of the season
week 18 which you want to talk about
weird things to say
week 18 where the league is going to
take two games from sunday and give them
to the worldwide leader
and uh abc and say let's see what these
d they're going to be games that are
important for teams to stay alive so
they can have
a chance to have a sunday result put
them in it's kind of like a playing game
is what the league is
is referring to in a way um that i mean
this is going to be fun this can be a
blast
yeah i mean there's just it just it just
the fun never stops throughout this
schedule it really doesn't
um and again to be
a part of this crew and to be a part of
something so iconic
and something that we all grew up
watching as kids
every time rich every time the music
comes on
every time i hear that in my headset and
you hear phil dean counting down
when you know he tells steve to go ahead
and go i mean
i literally i mean i'm not kidding you i
literally get goosebumps and i think
back to my father
you know when i was in the late 70s when
i'm like 9 10 years old and just begging
him to stay up
to half time to watch monday night
football and howard yes and
then the group would come on and i'm
going i'm actually talking about this
people are listening to me
talk about monday night football it's
it's surreal man
and these games are fantastic going to
pittsburgh week 17 cleveland and
pittsburgh yes
played against the steelers on monday
night when i was with the browns
i mean again i mean that's what i'm
saying is the story lines is right
themselves man i
i i just can't believe we thought four
months to wait until we kick it off just
for week one
and now your kids can watch dad on a
75-inch uh television
no question well you know what what's
funny though careful that's when you're
look louis everything shows up uh okay i
mean certainly if you got 4k whatever
you got your 5k
or whatever be careful yeah 8k
oh my gosh that's a lot of k be careful
believe me i was just watching
sportscenter and watching some of the
people on there i'm going oh
i can see everything
[Laughter]
it's funny you say i was just saying
that you all sit there man
let's see what they have for breakfast
looking at this tv a lot of cake yeah
hey before i let you go ask uh louis our
poll question
uh chris brockman please at rich eisen
show for people to vote right now go for
it chris brockman please
all right lewis it's frank gore's
birthday today who most deserve who most
deserves to make the pro football hall
of fame frank gore eli manning phillip
rivers julian edelman
uh if i i can only pick one yes sir
that's what that's uh this is sports
talk radio
it's twitter yeah there's no room for
nuance sir it's twitter it's sports talk
radio come on
oh geez you know i you know what uh
frank gore
who is it print core eli manning julia
edelman and phil and uh
philip rivers i probably have to go with
philip
i play wow okay what you know i i
look i i love philip look some of this
is subjective man of course
okay i mean i i know i know you like the
criteria for getting in the hall of fame
people get all up in
arms about this stuff but philip has
been one of my favorite he was one of
the greats for a long time he played on
some good football teams i know he
didn't win any super bowls
i know that people will say well he
didn't win a super bowl and eli wanted
you know i i get it and frank is a stud
there's no doubt about that julian i
don't really know i haven't really
looked into what julian's stats are
post-season some of the guys it's
post-season yeah it really is
it's when the money when the chips are
down he plays biggest
i'm going but i'm going with i'm going
with phillip man philip was one of my
favorites one of the smartest football
players that i have ever
witnessed play i mean he was just smart
he just didn't get the same
get the credit for it because you know
he was going up against guys
like tom and and uh and peyton and those
guys but philip
philp was a stud man i'm gonna go there
okay well louis riddick the reaction i'm
getting from my producer and friend
chris brockman across the way i don't
think that take holds up in 8k
in his opinion right there either so
that's all right it's okay
it's all good but you know what if you
guys ever want to drop by the house and
watch it man
yes let me know
thanks for the east coast man come on by
thanks for the call lewis appreciate it
let's chat soon you bet congrats on the
on the news set up louis riddick
everybody monday night football
that was awesome and so much more on
espn love his work love his takes love
his mind love his opinions love
his experience oh yeah truly he's the
best
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here